so we've been talking about this story
involving Washington Post journalist and
US resident Jamal Khashoggi and the
story has gotten to the point where we
now are on sort of version five of
explanations from Saudi Arabia about
what happened and we're gonna talk
through the entire thing to catch you up
on the story this started back on
October 2nd when Jamal khashoggi was
last seen he went to the Saudi embassy
in Istanbul Turkey reportedly to handle
some sort of logistical paperwork
regarding a divorce from his wife he
wanted to get a document certifying that
he indeed was no longer married to the
woman who is now his ex-wife and he
disappeared he was never seen again and
we had from a very early moment in the
story the President of the United States
Donald Trump sort of providing cover for
what was from the beginning very
obviously at least partially the
responsibility of Saudi Arabia if not
fully at one point sort of repeating
this idea that he got from a member of
the Saudi royal family that it could
have been anybody that was responsible
for Khashoggi zhh disappearance even
quote rogue killers so let's sort of
talk through the different stories that
we've now gotten from Saudi Arabia and
then we'll get back to Trump's reaction
in a moment so the first story from
Saudi Arabia was we have no idea just
we've got no clue we don't know anything
about it
this guy I guess he was in Turkey so you
say that we don't know we just don't
know anything at all the second story
became once there was video surveillance
of Jamal khashoggi going into the Saudi
Arabian consulate in Istanbul Turkey
that okay fine he went to the Saudi
Arabian consulate we don't know anything
about what he was doing there even
though it's a consulate embassy he left
quickly and we don't know what happened
anything could have happened after all
again he was in Turkey not in Saudi
Arabia we just have no idea whatsoever
the third story via Donald Trump from a
member of the Saudi royal family was
this idea that okay all right it does
appear that he was
killed but it could have been anybody it
could have been rogue killers we just
simply can't say and that's the point at
which it started to get really weird and
unbelievable particularly because we
started to see this resurgence of Donald
Trump's authoritarian tendencies where
he doesn't seem to believe anything that
we hear from our actual allies France
Canada we can't trust anybody but what
Putin tells Trump he parrots and repeats
and acts on or doesn't act on as is
sometimes the case what president air
Dewan or North Korean leader Kim jong-un
or in this case Saudi Arabia whatever
they tell him that's what he defers to
and that's what he seems to think of as
the most credible and the most likely or
at least that's what he publicly says so
that was Story number three
rogue killers we then found out because
of the early reporting of American media
based on sources inside Saudi Arabia
that the next story story number four as
I guess we're calling it was okay he did
actually die at the Saudi embassy which
of course has now become the goal post
have been moved so far that they're in a
different country where they don't even
play the same sports to use the
goalposts moving analogy he was at the
Embassy and he did die there but it was
an interrogation that went wrong now
that was an interesting one Pat because
the idea that it was an interrogation
gone wrong creates some gray area with
American renditions which also sometimes
go wrong and people die and this was
there was a very smart piece that I read
saying that if you're trying to get
Trump to do nothing a really clever way
is to start creating this gray area
where is an interrogation gone wrong
that different from an extraordinary
rendition by the CIA gone wrong and if
you're going to defend that policy as
Donald Trump has done can he even really
criticize Saudi Arabia it's not actually
that intelligent to make the analogy but
it's good enough for Trump to start
saying you know you know can I really
even criticize this and punish them for
even though it's way too vague
an explanation of course notice how
these stories do seem to be getting
closer and closer to the truth what we
assume is the truth but we're not quite
there yet yes so now we have Story
number five I will present to you Story
number five from Saudi Arabia is that
Jamal khashoggi died not in an
interrogation gone wrong but because he
got into a fight with people at the
Saudi embassy and he ended up dying okay
what they're saying is that there was
some kind of conversation or interaction
between Jamal khashoggi and people at
the Embassy and that led to a fight
which caused his death somehow now in
most fights that sort of spontaneously
break out people don't end up dead and
dismembered by individuals who fly in
with bone saws right normal fights don't
go that way and as you mentioned could
show he went to the embassy over a
domestic issue right trying to get
paperwork divorce his former wife yeah
get remarried how does that devolve into
some Royal Rumble where he's fighting
numerous people it must have been that
some people there decided they were
gonna remove a few of his fingers and
that angered him so he tried to put up a
fight and then they ended up killing him
because hey the guy was fighting after
all the timing of this fifth story was
the middle of the night
Saudi Arabia time Friday night in the US
sort of like putting a presidential
debate on a Sunday evening of a long
weekend Turkey claims to have audio
evidence proving that torture killing
and dismemberment took place and the the
Saudi Arabian royal family Saudi Arabian
spokespeople are saying that there have
been either 15 or 18 people detained as
part of an investigation into this
question one where is the body right
question where where is the body if
indeed you are now saying oh yeah we've
got a record of him at the Embassy we
know exactly how he died a fight
escalated where is the body we don't
have an answer to that question seems
the body was taken apart number two what
was the fight about we should know what
exactly escalated this fight and then
most importantly why would a 59 year old
by himself think to start a fight with
15 to 18 people in an embassy that is
known to be hostile to him does that
even count as a fight as far as
definitionally right acts
dental deaths in fights it should be
very very clear what escalated it and
how it devolved into that imagine if
this is the best story they have like
they clearly sat down and said okay
let's see what's the best story we can
come up with we'll say he died in a
fight if this is the best story they
came up with imagine the ones that they
didn't tell us yeah it's a slow drip
drip drip and it's satisfying no one we
need to hear more will anything happen
will there be repercussions probably not
why not well we pulled our audience
about that on the YouTube channel
community page we asked why do you think
the Trump administration is defending
Saudi Arabia after the murder of
journalist Jamal khashoggi 65% of our
audience believes that it's Donald
Trump's financial ties to Saudi money
that are keeping him from really taking
action here seventeen percent saying
that it is the weapons sales to Saudi
Arabia nine percent believe that the oil
market stability is the issue five
percent that Trump just loves strong men
like Mohammed bin Salman four percent
say something else so overwhelmingly our
audience believes that it's Trump's
connections to Saudi money a angle to
the story that is not discussed very
often is the rise of the mobster state
in Saudi Arabia there's a really good
spectator article that we're linking to
on YouTube which explains that for the
last six to ten years Saudi Arabia has
sort of put out this facade of
moderation we're gonna start letting
women drive we're going to sort of
normalize some relations with Israel for
example the point is to put out this
idea of normal assort of moderation
privately though they are still using
beheadings they are using corporal
punishment they're cracking down on the
so-called corruption that they want to
root out by torturing and killing people
if you're cracking down on corruption by
torturing and killing people are you
really moderating or are you not I think
it's an interesting question that that
bears asking I am really excited to tell
you about one of today's sponsors Green
orchid calm where you can use coupon
code Pakman to get 15% off of affordable
comfortable stylish clothes
manufactured with a conscience I have
talked plenty of times on this show
about how toxic the garment industry is
for the environment and especially how
horrible so many fashions supply chains
are for workers and green orchid offers
ecologically sustainable Fairtrade
clothing for men and women which you can
learn more about on their website
everything's totally transparent you can
read everything about where the clothing
is made how it was made what it's made
of
they have belts scarves jewelry shoes
even flip-flops
they've got dresses skirts and tops for
women shirts and shorts for men you
should have no problem finding something
that fits your style and green orchid
buys garments in small quantities so
there won't be hundreds of people
walking around wearing your same item
they also offer gift cards if you want
to give the gift of ethical clothing go
and shop for clothes without guilt feel
good about what you're buying go to
Green orchid dot-com it is the kind of
sponsor I love having on the show I've
put a link under this video and use
coupon code PA que ma n to get 15% off